Hey, Thoughty2 here.
In Athens in the state of Georgia there is
a tree that owns itself.
This tree is the only tree in the world that
is the legal landowner of the land it lives
upon.
Having fond memories of the tree when growing
up the landowner William H. Jackson wanted
to protect the tree forever.
So, in the early 1800s he went to court and
transferred the deeds for the land in an eight
foot radius around the tree, from himself
to the tree.
To this day the legality of the tree's property
rights have never been questioned.
Planet Earth has 57 million square miles of
land or 36 billion acres and until the day
comes when we set foot on other planets that's
all the land we have.
Land therefore is the most limited commodity
we have, thus it comes at a great price.
As the population increases and more homes
are needed to house the next generation, the
demand for land increases.
In the past 10 years alone land prices have
trebled, in some countries.
But who owns the world?
And I'm not talking about power and money
but the actual Earth you stand upon, from
the wilds of Alaska to Outer Mongolia who
really owns the dirt and gravel beneath your
feet and more importantly who owns your house
and the land it sits on.
Is it really you or is it in fact the bank,
the government or some kind of land and gentry?
Let's start with America and its 2.3 billion
acres of land across 50 states.
The biggest land owner in America is cable
billionaire John Malone who owns a staggering
2.2 million acres.
He owns enormous ranches in Wyoming, New Mexico
and Colorado.
Oh, he also owns Humewood Castle in Ireland,
because he thought it was pretty.
Malone is closely followed by Ted Turner who
owns 2 million acres of American land across
seven states.
He is a media mogul who founded CNN.
Turner's land includes 14 ranches, 28 homes
and the world's largest herd of privately
owned bison.
He also has four girlfriends, he spends a
week with each one per month, because if you're
a 78-year-old billionaire who owns a massive
chunk of America then why the hell not?
An Englishman's home is his castle, no matter
how big or small, your humble abode is yours
and no one can ever take it away from you.
Or can they?
And come to think of it, is it really yours?
If you own your home via leasehold you have
zero rights to the ownership of your property
or its land, absolutely none.
You are simply renting the property and have
decided to pay for the next 99 year's rent
upfront.
The freeholder is the true owner of the land
and everything upon it, he or she is your
landlord, for the next 99+ years.
If you are wealthy enough to own a flat or
even a house in London then you probably don't
actually own it, or the land.
This guy does instead, 26-year-old Hugh Grovesnor,
the 7th Duke of Westminster, who owns about
half of London.
He is worth over £12 billion, making him
the richest person under 30 years old in the
World.
And you are simply renting from him for a
very long time.
But what if you do own the freehold to your
property?
And what if you've paid off your mortgage,
with no interference from the bank, you must
then be the one true owner of your castle
and its land?
Well, not quite.
I'm sorry to burst your dream of setting up
your own country in your back garden but you
don't truly own any land.
In fact not many people do.
There's a centuries old doctrine of law called
"Absolute land ownership" which is fuzzy but
it means that you may hold the rights to a
piece of land and its title but you don't
"absolutely" own it.
In most countries the government owns the
entirety of the land in that country, all
you own is a title to that land, giving you
certain rights to it, but not absolute ownership.
And the government can forcefully buy your
house and land off you at any time if for
example, they wish to build a bypass through
your home, well you've got to build bypasses.
This is true for every country in the world,
after all if the government didn't own 100%
of the land within that country then it wouldn't
be a complete country, it would be Spain,
minus all these plots of land where people
have purchased property.
Each property owner would essentially own
their own little country and maps of the world
would get really complicated.
So countries have to own 100% of their land
in order to create and enforce laws within
that country's boundaries.
But in truth there is no such thing as true
land ownership, the laws surrounding land
ownership are really messy, and change completely
depending on which country you're in.
In reality you have essentially paid for some
rights over a piece of land, but your rights
to the land are overlapped by the rights of
other bodies, such as the government and the
monarchy, if there is one.
Speaking of Monarchies, that's when things
get really complicated.
For example, in England, the absolute land
owner is not the government, but The Crown,
an independent body who acts on behalf of
Her Majesty the Queen.
Queen Elizabeth II owns every square inch
of land of the United Kingdom.
When you buy a property in the UK you are
simply put on a map called the "Land Registry"
to identify that you own the title to that
plot of land.
In reality you don't own the land, you hold
it; you are a tenant of The Crown.
If you were to really buy that land outright,
you would have to draw up a sales contract
with Her Majesty and The Government who have
certain historic legal ties with The Crown.
But that would just but one less place for
Elizabeth to drive her Land Rover and walk
her Corgis, so I don't think that's going
to happen.
One element of the law that exemplifies the
fact that you don't actually own your own
land is that if you strike oil on your private
land in the UK, you have no rights to it.
The Crown automatically owns any oil or other
valuable minerals found below private properties,
and all you're entitled to, is compensation
to replace the soil once all the oil has been
extracted and sold for lots and lots of money,
none of which you will ever see.
But the British isles is not all that the
Her Majesty the Queen owns, far from it.
As a matter of fact, Queen Elizabeth II is
the largest land owner in the world, by a
large margin.
The Queen owns one-sixth of the Earth's land.
And she is the only person in the world that
owns entire countries.
Queen Elizabeth II owns 6.6 billion acres
of land and she is head of state of 16 countries,
collectively known as the Commonwealth Realm.
She owns the entire countries of Canada and
Australia, which are the second and sixth
largest countries in the world, respectively.
The Queen's total landholdings are worth an
estimated £25 trillion.
Which makes her, by a considerable margin,
the wealthiest person on the planet.
But it's not quite as simple as that, she
is more of a ceremonial owner of said countries.
Whilst she does technically own the land,
the individual country's governments have
ownership to the titles of the lands and they
profit from it.
The Crown doesn't actually see any profit
from much of its land holdings.
Because of this the Queen's actual estimated
wealth is somewhere around £275 million.
I mean that's not to be sniffed at, but it's
rather measly for someone who owns one-sixth
of the planet, excluding oceans.
She also owns a drive-thru McDonald's in Slough,
because why not when you're the Queen.
But symbolic or not she is undoubtedly the
world's largest landholder.
So who then, is following in her footsteps?
That would be King Salman of Saudi Arabia,
who inherited The Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
after the recent death of his half-brother
King Abdullah.
He owns 553 million acres in total, just 8%
of what the Queen owns.
But those 553 million acres are rich in oil,
which gives The Kingdom of Saudi Arabia a
GDP of $646 billion.
At number three on the land owner list is
none other than Pope Francis.
The pope owns the Vatican City, which is its
own nation state.
But isn't the Vatican also the smallest country
in the World?
Yes, it most definitely is, at just 108 acres.
So how does that make the Pope the world's
third largest landowner?
Well, the Catholic church actually owns 177
million acres of land world-wide, which means
the Pope owns 177 million acres of land.
That of course includes every religious institution,
diocese and Vatican-owned embassies to the
Holy See, which are in 81 countries.
If all land was divided equally between every
person on the planet then every single person
would own roughly 5 acres of land.
Just over 3 football pitches each.
But of course it isn't, land ownership has
always been about power, wealth and social
class and it still is.
Every time you mow your lawn you are imitating
the aristocrats of the past.
In a figurative sense, because of course,
wealthy aristocrats definitely didn't mow
their own lawns.
You see the reason lawns were invented in
the first place was to show off and demonstrate
power.
It was a way of saying, hey look everyone,
we're so bloody rich we can afford to own
and maintain vast areas of land which we have
no real use for.
But look, isn't it impressive, with its shrubberies,
mazes and fountains.
Yes, lots and lots of fountains.
In medieval times 100% of the land your average
person owned was used to either build upon
and live in, or to grow food to feed your
family.
Most people would starve if they decided to
grow topiary instead of cabbages.
You can't eat topiary, I've tried.
So wealthy kings, princes, lords and ladies
would purposely clear all trees from their
excessive areas of unused land and grow grass
upon it instead, creating a meadow or lawn.
This served two purposes.
Firstly it was now far easier to see people
trying to invade their castle and secondly
they could show off how much spare land they
had.
This was even more impressive back then because
of course, the lawn mower didn't exist.
Neatly trimmed grass lawns has to be painstakingly
cut by hand by servants wielding scythes and
shears.
The Palace of Versailles is a prime example
of this showy-offery.
Even with modern gardening tools, the amount
of money, time and manpower that goes into
maintaining a garden this stunning is rather
impressive.
The trend of maintaining lawns to impress
others has continued throughout the centuries.
And although the lawns have become significantly
smaller with an increasing population, your
neighbour will probably still sneer at it,
if you don't keep it nicely trimmed, because
this medieval tradition has become ingrained
within our culture.
But who cares if its exorbitant and a completely
unnecessary, you are the king of your castle.
And okay you don't really own it, but who
cares, get out there and mow your lawn.
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this video then please click
here to support me on Patreon.
Click here to watch another video and if you
haven't already, don't forget to subscribe.